this praying mantis is sporting some
unusual eyewear 3d glasses oh my god she
moves in a kind of strike ease of way
these simple bits of colored plastic are
helping untangle the inner workings of
the Mantis brain oh my god
I'm ally Jennings and I've come to
Newcastle in the UK where researchers
are testing mantises sophisticated
visual abilities and mapping the brain
cells responsible for their 3d vision so
the cool thing about praying mantids
are as far as we know at the moment
they're the only insects that actually
have stereoscopic depth perception
stereoscopic vision in humans involves
some pretty complex neural circuitry
understanding how such a small insect
brain manages the task could help
engineers design machines that could see
in 3d she is beautiful
[Music]
praying mantises are formidable hunters
like humans their depth perception
depends on having two eyes set slightly
apart so that each eye sees the world
from a slightly different angle
comparing the two images allows the
brain to estimate how far away an object
is for decades people have used 3d
glasses to create the illusion of depth
two images can be laid on top of each
other each a different color and in a
slightly different position colored
lenses filter out one of the colors so
that each eye only sees one of the
images tricking the brain into thinking
it's seeing a 3d object so what's going
on here is we're displaying this disc
twice once your left arm and your right
eye into slightly different positions
Jenny Reed is using 3d glasses to test
stereoscopic or 3d vision in mantises
but the images work just as well on
humans yeah it's like a single black
spot that's just jumped out the screens
back there I feel like a mountain just
like me when a mantis thinks it sees
something within striking distance it
tries to grab it and Jenny uses this
behavior to test their 3d vision so we
can use our 3d to manipulate the
apparent distance of objects and when an
animal reaches out tries to grab it then
we know it's seeing it in 3d but mantis
vision doesn't work exactly like ours
they can see some things that we can't
jenny showed me another kind of stimulus
where the solid circles were replaced by
this moving pattern the Mantis grabs out
as before apparently seeing a 3d shape
but when I looked I couldn't make sense
of it ah I can see a circle but it's not
3d so in this image your left eye is
looking at a pattern of random dots and
your right eye is looking at a
completely different unrelated random
pattern of dots the mismatched inputs in
each I meant my brain couldn't interpret
what I was seeing as a single object but
mantis vision is different it seems to
be based more on change in other words
which bits of the image are moving but
how does it work to find out Rony Rosner
has begun to map the nerve cells
involved
these are the electrical pulses neurons
use to communicate with with each other
Rani places electrodes inside individual
neurons in a mantises brain and records
electrical signals while showing the
Mantis the 3d moving circle Rani uses
this setup to figure out what it is of
particular neurons are responding to
once he's found an interesting neuron
it's off to the microscope to have a
closer look so what you're seeing here
is an actual nerve cell in the praying
mantis brain that has been stained and
now finally we know how the neuron
actually looks like which we recorded
earlier on Rani is then able to
construct 3d images of each nerve cell
he studies this particular cell is one
of the most exciting neurons being
recorded from because it responds to
prey like objects in the striking range
of the praying mantis so when we saw the
Mantis striking a neuron like that would
have been firing exactly and you can get
a better understanding in this way of
where the neuron might receive input
here for example or here in word bite
sent it's our food here
ronnie hopes to build a map of all the
neurons involved in 3d vision in the
Mantis since they're relatively small
and simple creatures you might expect
that the wiring behind their
stereoscopic vision would also be very
simple but Ronnie and Jenny are
discovering some surprisingly
sophisticated circuitry what one is
finding is that there's actually a
multitude of neurons different classes
of neurons that are tuned to different
distances and different directions so it
seems like the circuitry underlying
mantis stereopsis is surprisingly
complex and actually quite similar to
what we find in mammals but mantises do
see differently to us they base their
depth perception on changes and movement
in the images they're seeing and it
seems that using change in this way may
be the key to making stereopsis simple
enough to be implemented in an insect
brain so if you can work out the
circuitry behind mantis 3d vision can
you use that in some way yeah I think so
people have already tried to give
machines 3d stereoscopic vision but many
of those algorithms have been based very
much on human style stereopsis which of
course might be entirely appropriate for
some applications but there are other
situations where for example if you had
a very low-power robot may be an
autonomous drone where it has to be
lightweight can't have a lot of battery
life then maybe mantis stereopsis which
is based on change over time might be a
good Avenue to explore a robot with
mantis-like vision could be simple yet
effective and having another model of
stereopsis to work from could help
engineers come up with a whole new
design for robot vision but actually
figuring out every element of these
complex circuits
take more time or experiments and of
course more mantises wearing tiny 3d
glasses I'm just wondering right so
basically can it can it stab through my
schedule no no you don't worry it can't
do that well I mean not significant op
through your skin isn't there's not
gonna be like major blood wow that is so
unreal sorry